what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to the
hot
crazy matrix scale a million of you guys
have commented that you wanted this
video so today i'm going to do it before
i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and do not forget
to ring that notification bell as you
guys know i'm trying to get to 20 000
subscribers and each and every one of
you
helps so this is the uni oh my gosh this
is so blurry commercial hot crazy matrix
it's everything a young man needs to
know about women
i've developed this on my own over 46
years living on the earth so
this is how it works
you have your crazy axis
and your hot axis hot
is as usual measured from zero to ten
we're all familiar with that
okay crazy is measured from four to ten
because of course there's no such thing
as a woman who's not at least a four
crate
[Laughter]
this is your hot crazy line right here
very important that you keep in mind
where the hot crazy line is
as a rule oh this is your no-go zone we
do not
hang around and date and
marry women who are not at least in our
mind of five
so this is your no go zone you don't go
here
we just rule this out life is better
this way
that's the way it is all right um above
a five
and two about an eight
and below the crazy line
this is your fun zone you can hang out
here
and and meet these girls and spend time
with them
that's your fun zone but keep in mind
when you're in the fun zone
you want to move out of the fun zone
to a more permanent location okay
so that's the fun zone above a five hot
below an eight hot and below the crazy
line
this means these are most of the time
not crazy
okay above the danger zone above the uh
above the crazy line we have
the danger zone this is your red heads
your strippers
anyone redheads i feel personally
attacked named tiffany
um this is hairdressers this is where
this is where your car gets keyed
you get a bunny in the pot uh your tires
get slashed and you wind up in jail
um now now that we have some of the
chart
filled in we've got a couple more pieces
to put in but at this point understand
something
this is not a static environment this is
a situation where you have got to
uh use this matrix over time
to develop some reliable data it's like
a dope chart okay
you on because at any moment in time
any woman that you have previously
located on this chart
can vanish from that location and appear
anywhere else on the chart
so what you have to do is over time
collect some data
once you have a cluster of data points
you can begin to consider that reliable
now
moving so so good point you you learn
more about people over
time okay you have this zone here
this is below the crazy line above and
eight hot
but still you know about a seven crazy
this is your date zone
you can stay in the date zone
indefinitely these are women that you
introduce to your friends and your
family
they're they're good looking and they're
reasonably not
crazy most of the time okay so this is
you can stay here indefinitely
now
above an eight hot and between about a
seven and a five
crazy this is your wife's own
okay when you meet this girl you should
consider a long-term relationship
uh this zone is not scaled to size
this this is a this is a representation
and not an actual
this is not a pie chart showing you how
many of these people are out there this
is simply why is this guy making this
scale
i'm not trying to be rude but does does
he look like he could be
a representation of what you're after
you want to be
five to seven crazy above and eight hot
that's your wife's own okay now
below five crazy and above and eight hot
this is your unicorn zone these things
don't exist
if you find a unicorn please capture it
safely keep it alive
we'd like to study it and maybe look at
how to replicate that
okay so i was explaining this to a guy
one time and he said wait a minute
i met this girl and she's like smoking
hot she's like at least a nine
and she's chill she's co totally cool
she's like not even a three crazy she's
an actor
i said you're telling me you've met a
girl she's a nine hot
and she's like a two or three crazy he
said yeah man i like her a lot
i said you should be careful that's a
dude you're talking to a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so you got your you got to be careful
because down here
below a four crazy and above an eight
hot you're probably talking to a dude
that is the universal hot crazy matrix
all right dana that was pretty good now
let me ask you
like for the for the women watching is
there a male version of that i mean oh
yeah would it also be
oh yeah it's a little simpler if a dude
is super hot okay yeah it's a little
simpler but we can do it real quick it
doesn't take very long at all
for women this is your this is your
matrix you got your cute axis
and you got your money axis okay
and uh if you have there's only three
sections
women have a very large no-go zone
this is for dudes who are neither hot
nor have a lot of money
you'll notice over here this is the
husband's section
uh once you cross a line and have
sufficient amounts of money
it is no longer relevant how hot you are
and then women have a fun
zone here where a dude is broke but hot
that that is the that is the cute versus
rich
matrix uh for women
oh my gosh that's hilarious um
yeah i mean this sounds like the
manosphere
in literally a nutshell let me know in
the comments if you guys agree or you
disagree
um i just keep laughing
that was so funny and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel